abone ol
[Müzik]
Herkese
merhabalar bu dünyada Bilim Teknoloji
mühendislik ve matematik alanlarından
mezun her yüz kişiden yalnızca 19'un
kadın olduğunu biliyor muydunuz
bu adam 1980'li yıllara gittiğimizde her
yüz kişiden 35 kadına çıkıyor Bir
taraftan da şu var lise çağındaki
gençlere hangi alanda eğitim görmek
istiyorsun Diye sorduğumuzda her 100
kadından 75'i bu alanlardan birini
tercih edeceğini söylüyor
ne demek ki biz bir noktada bu
potansiyeli kaybediyoruz bu alanların
içerisinde özellikle teknolojinin kadın
güçlenmesinde ayrı bir yeri olduğunu
düşünüyorum ama kadın güçlenmesinden
Konuşacaksak önce teşvik etmeliyiz değil
mi
oy oy
asidi 2020 verilerine göre Türkiye'de
15-29 yaş arası her 100 kadından 40'ı ne
eğitim ne de istihdam da yer alıyor ve
bunun büyük bir bölümü bir tercih değil
Ya ben tercih yapabilenler dedim şanslı
olan taraftayım güçlü kadınlar
modellerle dolu bir ayarladım dedim ve
hiçbir zaman hiç kimse bana sen bunu
yapamazsın sen buraya gidemezsin sen onu
Söyleyemezsin sen bunu yiyemezsin
demedim Dedim ya şanslıydım ama şanslı
olmakla birlikte aynı şanslı ailede
olmamış bir ellerinde her zaman farkında
olarak büküldüm burada ekonomik bir şans
lan kesinlikle bahsetmedim fırsat
eşitliği anlatmak istediğim ve böyle bir
farkındalığın bir insana Gelişme çağında
verilecek en büyük farklılıklardan biri
olduğunu düşünüyorum
çocukluk Yıllarım genelde sporla geçti
eski milli cimnastikçim
Ritmik Jimnastik dünyada hala olumsuza
yalnızca kadınlar tarafından yapılan
spor öyle bir ortamda büyüyünce şunu
görüyorsunuz cesaret başarının ta
kendisidir
7-8 yaşlarında yüzlerce kişinin
ortasında bir minbere çıkıp yaşının çok
çok üstüne en son gerektiren hareketleri
kusursuz bir şekilde yapabilen kız
çocuklarından bahsediyorum onların
gözlerine baktığım zaman da cesaretle
tanışıyorsunuz
performanslarıyla Büyümek Tabi bir
taraftan uzun antrenman saatleri
yarışmalar kamplar turnuvalarda erken
çocukluk ve ilk gençlik yıllarından
geriye çok şey bırakmıyor açıkçası
Bu üniversite ilk başladığım yılda
üniversite Olimpiyatları olan
üniversiteye hazırlanıyordu queue bunun
uzun hazırlık dönemi ardından gelen uzun
yarışma dönemi sonunda okula bir de
hanım devamsızlıktan sınıfta kalmak
üzereyim şimdi bu noktada spor ve eğitim
hayatının aynı anda gitmedi argümanı
kesinlikle katılmadığı mı belirtmek
istiyorum üniversitede katılmak benim
için spor Kaderim İçinden bir tercihte
eğitim hayatımı Oradan geri
döndürebilmek ise tamamen sporcusu ile
oldu aslında yani performans sporu ve
akademik Hayat ikisinide temelinde
Aslında çok çalışma ve Disiplin yatıyor
Bir de ikisini de bir diğer ortak
noktası Bence idealizm
idealist bir tercih yaparak üniversitede
temel bir okumaya karar verdim kimya
bölümüne başladım ve benim bildiğim
sevgisiyle oyunlarda tanıştım büyük
teorilerin hem evreni hem de hücre
yapısını açıklamadaki kusursuz
başarısını veya evrenin genişlediğini
dediğimiz yöntemle atom bu bağlayan
bağların uzamasını izlediğimiz yöntem
aynı olduğunu görmek beni çok
etkilemişti
adeta kusursuz bir ertele Şimdi sizlere
bu noktada kısa bir süreliğine lise
yıllarımızda geri döndürmek istiyorum
sınıfta oturuyoruz tahtada kocaman
kocaman denklemler yazıyor Tahta ders
boyunca üç kere dolmuş boşalmış yeniden
doğmuş arka sıralardan bir yerden bir
homurdanma gelir hocam bunlar gelecekte
bizim ne işimize yarayacak
Sonra ikisi büyür İş hayatına atılır bir
toplantıdan diğerine İstanbul trafiğinde
yetişebilmek için arabasına atlar ve GPS
uygulamasını açar telefonda bunu
yaptığında Aslında fizikte doppler
etkisi olarak geçen fenomeni kullanarak
konumunu belirlemeye ve hızlı
belirlemeye başlamıştır Yani aslında
soru hocam bunlar Gerçekten ne işimize
yarayacak değil de bu neden yapılıyor
acaba veya Ben bununla ileride ne
yapabilirim olsa konulan başka yerlere
gelecek Aslı ya o yüzden bence temel
bilim eğitimi İyidir insana iyi bir
hayat vizyonu verir Her Şimdi ben bugün
sizlerin huzurunda bir araştırmacı ve
bir girişimci olarak bunlar benim
Akademi girişimci Hikayem doktora
yıllarının sonlarına doğru daha etkin
tarım yöntemleri üzerine yaptım
okumalarla başlıyor Aslında
bir taraftan da tabii gelecekte Dünya
nasıl bir yer olacak sorusu her meraktan
aklının bir köşesinde değil mi mi
gelecek deneyeceğiz Sonuçta benim
aklımın bir köşesinde mesela veya
gelecekte Toprak Ana bize ne sunabilecek
bugün Sizlerin de bildiği üzere masum
görünümlü tarım sektörü Aslında küresel
ısınma en çok katkı sağlayan sektör bunu
şu şekilde örneklendirme biliriz
yeryüzüne kullandığımız bütün motorlu
araçları düşünün bütün kişisel
araçlarımız toplu taşıma araçları
kamyonlar uçaklar trenler tarım ve
hayvancılık sektörü bunların hepsinin
toplamından daha fazla sera gazı salımı
yapıyor
ve sera gazı salımı karbon ayakizi gibi
konulara bazı potansiyel çözümlerimiz
mevcut iyi haber doğru çevre
politikaları uygularsak bunları
yavaşlatmak Hatta bir nokta durdurmak
mümkün gibi görünüyor ama çevreye doğaya
ve doğal kaynaklara verdiğimiz zararın
geri dönüşü çok zor Maalesef ve yine bu
tatlış tarım sektörü aynı zamanda
suyunda en büyük kullanıcılarından ve
tarımsal atıklardan dolayı sahalara
uyguladığımız organik gübreler olsun
kimyasal gübreler olsun böcek ilacı
olarak kullandığımız pestisit gibi tarım
girdilerinin fazlalığından dolayı da
suyun en büyük kirleticilerden bir
ibadet olan sana atarım sıra tiplerinden
biri olan vahşi sulama Yani bir bir
tarlayı su bastırarak sulama yöntemi
Aslında bu bizim içme kaynaklarımızın en
büyük kullanıcısı vahşi sulama Hatta az
gelişmiş ülkelerde vahşi sulama
pratiklere içme suyunun yüzde doksanı
kullanıyor
bu
komasına tarım sektöründe bunun gibi
bazı birçok açıkçası eksikler ve yanlış
uygulamalar mevcut ve bunların artık
teknoloji destekli değişmesi gerekiyor
dünya ve teknoloji çok hızlı bir yere
gidiyor tarım sektöründe artık buna ayak
uydurmasın zamanı geldi
konvansiyonel tarif ettikleri getirdiği
çevre sorunları da malumunuz oldukça çok
buna bir örnek verebilir mi Sağ sahalara
uyguladığımız pestisitlerin böcek
ilaçlarının her bir tonunun yalnızca bir
kilogram hedefine ulaşıyor geri kalan
999 kilogramı toprakta bitki de suda
birikip malum çevre sonuçları neden
oluyor zaten bu kadar çokken bir de bir
taraftan artan gıda talebi ile Bunlar
çok daha baskın hale geliyor bu dünya
verilerine göre Dünya Bankası verilerine
göre 2050 yılında Dünya nüfusunun 10
milyar olması bekleniyor bu ve Bu artan
nüfusu doyurabilmek için aynı yıllarda
şimdikinden yüzde yetmiş daha fazla
tarım üretim yapmamız gerekiyor ama bir
taraftan iklim değişikliği kuraklık
giderek artan şehirleşme de bizim tarım
arazileri giderek küçülüyor Bütün
bunlardan yola çıkarak gittikçe küçülen
tarım arazilerinin de daha etkin tarım
yöntemleri geliştirmek için teknolojiden
faydalandığımız Sizler de takdir
edersiniz ki şart Peki ama nasıl
yapacağız
cevap Aslında bu soruyu sorarak başlıyor
soru sorarak merak ederek bilgi
biriktirerek biliminde bilimsel
düşüncenin bu tür bu tarz zorlukların
üstesinden gelebileceğini benimseyerek
aslında tam da bu şekilde Az önce
anlattığım kötü gidişata bir potansiyel
çözümümüz mevcut buna bazıları tarım 40
diyor bazıları teknolojik tarım Bence
ikisi eş anlamlı Şimdi sizlere Az önceki
lise sıralarından alıp gelecek de Bir
tarlaya götürmek istiyorum tarım 40 da
bitirmiş yakın gelecekte Bir tarlaya
gittiğimizde orada ne göreceğiz
Öncelikle uydularla dronlarla sensör
sistemleri bunların kombinasyonlarıyla
en ufak bir tarım zararlısı bile 7/24
izlendiği ve tespit edildiği bir sahada
bulacağız kendimize burada aynı zamanda
robotik otomasyon ile gübreleme ve
tohumlama yapılıyor olacak veya gelişen
yeni nesil malzeme teknolojileri ile
tarım girdilerinin doğaya ve doğal
kaynaklara zarar vermeden kullanıldığını
göreceğiz veya yine gelişen bilgi
teknolojileriyle ürün bölümünü maksimize
edildiği Hatta önümüzdeki on yıllık ürün
bölümlerinin tahminlerini yapıldığı bir
alanda bulacağız kendimizi
da buna yakın gelecek dedim Çünkü
aslında tarım 40 dönüşüm bir süredir
bizimle ve bu teknolojinin bazıları önce
sahalarda şimdiden uygulanmaya başlandı
çok uzak bir hayal değil aslında
anlattıklarım Elimizi uzatsak o
ulaşabileceğimiz
konvansiyonel tarım dan kaynaklı bu
girdilerin tarım girdilerinin aşırı
kullanımı dedik ya az önce buna nasıl
aşırı kullanımı regüle etmek üzere son
zamanlarda bazı teknolojik gelişmeler
yapılmaya başlanmış durumda ve bu konu
Aslında tarım dörtlü Tam da o da
konularından Biri haline gelmiş durumda
bu teknolojide baktığınızda bana Neyin
doğru yapıldı diye soracak olursanız ben
öncelikle problem tanımı doğru
yapıldığını düşünüyor
Bu bir kimyasalın bir tarım gibisin
fazlasını kullanımı beyaz suyun
fazlasını kullanımı kimyasal ın veya
suyu Suçumu Hayır değil kullanım
patiklerimiz hatalar Demek ki
teknolojinin bu kullanım pratikleri ile
ilgili edecek şekilde ilerlemesi
gerekiyor
Yani bir problemi doğru soruyu sorup
doğru veriler ışığında yaklaşırsak bir
şekilde çıkış yolu buluyoruz ama Tabii
bunun için anca Ne yapacağız Hayal
edeceğiz Elimizi uzatacağız ve hatta
koyabiliyor Sak Elimizi taşın altına
koyacağız
ben kendim de elimi taşın altına koymaya
çalıştım kimya mezunuyum malzemesi
doktorası yaptım ve laboratuvarda
geliştirdiğimiz bir teknoloji Bence
Dünyaya en faydalı olabileceğini
düşündüm alanda uygulamak üzere bir
çekirdek şirket kurduk bu çekirdek
şirket kurulumunda sirket Kurumu
anamızdan Öncelikle bahsetmek istedim
şirket kurmak için bir çoğunuz
biliyorsunuzdur bir noktada ticaret
sicil odasına gidip ismini onaylı
atmamız gerekiyor biz oraya giderken
şirketin isminden evindeki 3 kurucu
ortağı ve üçümüzün baş harfleri olan soy
teknoloji olacaktı gayet güzel her şey
Ticaret Odasına girdik oradaki beyefendi
ile bi' Efendim sadece teknoloji olmaz
bunun ne teknolojisi olduğu belli değil
sadece tarım olmaz öyledir böyledir diye
bir Tartışmanın ardından soytarım
teknoloji aşağıya imza atıp çıktık Şu
çıktıktan yarım saat sonra fark ettik 3
doktoralı İnsan ilk şirketimizin adını
Soytarı koyup çıkmıştık Bu köyde kaldı
değiştiremedik
soykırımla geliştirdiğimiz teknolojimiz
soracağız Teknik olarak baktığımızda bir
nanokompozit süper aktör Ben polimer
olarak geçiyor soya değil daha
anlaşılabilir ismiyle anlatmaya çalışır
Ya aslında Bence gelişmiş bir su
maymuncuğu diyebiliriz çocukken
oynadığım Su maymuncukları gibi
üretiliyor Daha sonrasında kuru bir
şekilde toprağın içerisinde uygulanıyor
Yağmur sularını ve sulama sularının
fazlasını içerisinde emerek ağırlığının
600 katına kadar şişiyor sonra kuraklık
döneminde bu içerisinde muhafaza ettiği
suyu yavaş bir şekilde toprağa sağlıyor
Böylece bitkilerin kuraklıktan Hatta
düzensiz yavaş rejimlere ardından gelen
kuraklıktan etkilenmesini engellemiş
oluyor ve suyunda kullanımını azaltıyor
yani Bir nevi sigorta mekanizması gibi
düşünebiliriz
bu solucan işiyle birlikte kendimi bir
anda girişimci akademisyen şapkası
altında buldum girişimci akademisyen
kadın teknoloji girişimcisi akademisyen
gibi konular Türkiye'de Görece yeni
konseptler olmakla birlikte bazı Öncü
kuruluşlar bunu çoktan benimsemiş
durumda Yani aslında akademik kariyer
Kafamızdaki Akademi Center atıp ile
sınırlı kalmak zorunda değil girişimci
akademisyen araştırmacı akademisinden
başka türlü akademik kariyerde mümkün
her iki sektörün tam ortasında kalmanın
bazı zorlukları var Tabi ki öncelikle
iki işiniz birden oluyor veya bir
girişimci akademisyen iseniz 48 saat
süren bir laboratuvar günün ardından
mali müşavirimiz arayıp işte Mehmet Bey
Mustafa neydi tevkifatlı fatura nasıl
kesiliyor Bunlar nedir gibi sorularla
yaşamayı öğreniyorsunuz İnsan bir
şekilde öğreniyor bunların hepsini işin
bir de ikram tarafı var tabi
girişimcilik Dünyası o Evet hızlı bir
devrin içerisinde her gün yeni bir
teknolojinin yeni bir vizyonun yeni bir
hayalini ortaya çıktı bir alan Ken
akademide bir o kadar ağır başlı
ayakları yere sağlam basan kendinden
emin olmadan bir sonraki adıma geçmeyin
öğretiyor insana
şimdi bu bir çelişki ama aynı zamanda
Bence İki tarafa da kaza katan
özellikleri olduğunu düşünüyorum
Öncelikle akademik kökenli olup ayakları
yere sağlam basan girişimlerin
girişimcilik dünyasında öne çıktığını ve
değerli olduğunu düşünüyorum diğer bir
taraftan bakacak olursak da asansör
sunumu diye bir gerçek var
barsız elinizdeki teknolojiyi
karşınızdaki yatırımcıya üç dakika
içerisinde anlayabileceği en basit dille
anlatarak Bir de mümkünse sonunda para
istemeniz gerekiyor
elindeki Teknolojiyi geliştirdim bir
teori veya bir inovasyonu Karşındakine
en sade en basit değil anlatabilme de
akademiye faydası olduğu düşüncesindeyiz
daha sonra karışımımızı teknoloji
kısmının yanı sıra aynı zamanda sosyal
etki kısmı da beni oldukça mutlu ediyor
açıkçası çünkü sol celia yapısı gereği
bir iklim değişikliğini adaptasyon iklim
değişikliği mücadele yöntemi olarak
geçiyor Ve bu da hem günümüzün hem de
geleceğin en önemli sorunlarından biri
ne dokundu anlamına geliyor Bir taraftan
da biz kadın Çoğunlukla bir girişimiz ve
yolumuza kadın çiftçilerle kadın
üreticilerle birlikte yürümeye
çalışıyoruz başta şanslı olduğumu
söylemiştim şans olmanın getirdiği
sorumluluklardan biri bence daha az
şansına Kapağı açmak
Toprak Türkçede Toprak Ana olarak
geçiyor ama tapusu çoğunlukla babadan
oğla aktarılıyor ki böyle olması da
kadın Çiftçilere daha ilk aşamada zaman
taşı durmayı düşürüyor biz onlarla
birlikte yaptığımız çalışmalarda
Birbirimize destek olup birbirimizin
bilmediği kısımlarda eksikleri kapatıp
birbirimizden öğrenerek Aslında
sorunları bunu bir sonra çok daha
rahatlıkla açabildiğimiz gördük bir
örnek verecek olursak yakın zamanda
gelecek kadınların bereketli ellerinde
yaşayabilecek isimli bir projemizi kütle
falan ay laf olmadık Bu projede Biz
kendi ürünümüz olan Soydan üretip kadın
Çiftçilere iletiyoruz ve kendilerinden
soy Celle zirai üretim yapmalarını
istiyoruz Tabii bunu yaparken Soldier
ile birlikte deneme yaptıkları
alanlardaki ürünlerinde ön alım
garantisi veriyoruz bununla hem
kendilerini bir nebze olsun avantajlı
başlangıç sağlamayı hem de aynı zamanda
üretim ekosisteminde kadın Çiftçi daha
görünür hale getirmeyi hedefliyoruz Daha
sonrasında bu alanlarda üretilen ürünler
yine kadın kooperatiflerine gidip
işlenerek reçel salça meyve kurusu gibi
sanırım bu Kooperatifleri gibi olarak
dönüyor ve böylece topraktan çatala
Hatta laboratuardan topraktan çatala
döngüsünü tamamlamış oluyoruz
hoca teknolojimizi bu tarzda kadın
Çiftçilere anlatmak için ilk başta yola
çıkmaya çalıştık ama çıkamadık Çünkü ben
de mi dönemin deydik Dolayısıyla bütün
toplantılarımız onların yapmak
zorundaydık çiftçilerle görüşmelerimizi
toplantılardan birinde Adalet teyze ile
tanıştım Adalet teyze 70 yaşında
Mersin'de yaşayan bir çiftçi
bu aslında bu toplantılarda Çiftçilere
ölümü anlatıp Bir de aynı zamanda
projemize katılmaya ikna etmeye
çalışıyoruz ama zorlanıyoruz Çünkü
birincisi yanlarında değiliz ürünü
elleriyle tutup gözleriyle göremiyorlar
evde Diğer taraftan bir çok çeşitli
sebepten dolayı günümüzde şu an tarım
üreticisi girdi maliyeti 1 TL
artırabilecek durumu Maalesef yok ürün
gerçekten işe yaradığını görse bile
satın alamayacağını düşünüyor
ve o toplantılardan birine Adalet teyze
hiç bir teknoloji sıkıntı yaşamadan cep
telefonuyla bağlandığı Tam bir saat
sonra boyunca konuşulan bütün
argümanları bütün endişeleri dinledi ve
hiç kimse gönüllü olmazken elini
kaldırıp proje ilk gönüllü olan oldu
cesaret dedi ki ben yaparım şu kadar
ağzım var bu kadar un yetiştiriyorum
bana ne kadar soracağız gerekiyorsa
hesaplayın gönderin Adalet Teyzenin
kocası duruşu o gün diğer Çiftçilere de
Aslında bir nevi ilham olup projemizin
Bence kaderini ve gidişatını değiştirdi
ve da aynı zamanda Adalet teyze o güçlü
kararlı kadın üretici duruşuyla bizim
gibi işe Yeni başlayanlara çok güzel bir
hayat dersi varmış oldu
sonra bütün bunları alırken Geçtiğimiz
aylarda Bu konuşmanın teklifi geldi Ama
ben de çok mutlu olmuştum Çünkü TED
konuşması Bence insanın hayatında bir
mihenk taşıdır Ben bunu böyle görüyorum
Yakın arkadaşlarından birini aradım
kendisi Kız meslek lisesinde öğretmendir
sesin kötü geliyordu ne oldu diye sordum
ve az önce öğrencilerinden birinin Kadın
cinayetine kurban gittiği haberini
aldığını söyledi
sonra haber benimle paylaştı bu sosyal
medya görüntüleri vardı haberin
içerisinde onları açtım ve o gün 17
yaşında öldürülen Asiye Atalay'ın sosyal
medyasında şu yazıyordu başka bir yerde
Ama bu noktadan sonra artık bu konuşma
yapmak zorundaydım şu kadın
cinayetleriyle hepimiz biraz ölüyoruz
ama bir taraftan daha bizim Yapacak çok
işimiz var açacak çok TP lerimiz yıkacak
çok cam tavan larımız var değil mi
Biz Kadınlar bunların hepsini seve seve
aşarız O Tepelere aşarız o cam Tavanları
büyük bir şevkle yukarı zaman başta
teşvik demiştim ya keşke bir noktada
geleceğiz eminim inanıyorum ama lütfen
önce kadını yaşatalım
Çok teşekkür ederim canım